6-Night English from BBCLearningEnglish.com
Hello, this is 6-minute English from BBC Learning English. I'm Neil.
And I'm Beth.
In every language, there's one word which has special power over us, our name.
Our senses, feelings and whole identity are closely linked to our name.
Yet strangely, our name isn't usually something we choose. It's given to us by our parents.
But what if the name you are given at birth doesn't fit?
Maybe you simply don't like it. Or maybe there are bigger reasons for wanting to change your name.
Reasons connected with historical injustices or unfair events in the past.
In this programme, we'll be meeting two people whose family history
has caused them to consider changing their name. And as usual, we'll be learning some useful
new vocabulary as well. Sounds good, Beth. But first, I have a question for you.
My name, Neil, is a British name and was given to me at birth.
But names change a lot between cultures and religions. Many Muslim boys are named Mohammed.
Indian boys are often called Ram or Krishna. And in Mexico, some boys are named Hesus.
So, according to a recent global survey, what is currently the world's most popular boy's name?
Is it A, Hesus, B, Muhammad or C, Noah?
Hmm, I guess it's Mohammed.
Okay, Beth, I'll reveal the answer at the end of the programme.
In Britain, a person's first name is also called their Christian name.
And in Christianity, many names have a religious meaning.
The name John, for example, means God is good. Anderson Jeremiah is the Bishop of Edmonton.
He was born in South India, but he doesn't have a traditional Indian sounding name.
Here, Bishop Jeremiah explains the roots of his name to BBC World Service programme Heart and Soul.
It was a name of one John Anderson. He was a first educational missionary who came and worked and
set up several schools in South India who had very noble ambitions.
But also, as with any missionaries, he was a big collaborator of the colonial establishment at that
point in time. So, he has a very strong baggage that goes with it. So, Anderson is my Christian name.
And Jeremiah is my dad's name.
Bishop Anderson Jeremiah's name comes from another man, John Anderson, a Christian missionary
during the British Empire. The history of the British Empire in India is controversial,
with many views on all sides. Bishop Jeremiah thinks that some of the empire's missionaries
were noble, meaning admirable or morally good. But nevertheless, John Anderson was part of a violent
and exploitative empire. Bishop Jeremiah uses the word baggage to describe the beliefs,
especially outdated or unhelpful beliefs, which influence how people think.
Emotional baggage tends to influence the feelings of one individual, while historical baggage can
affect whole societies. In India, names serve an important purpose to signify social status.
Low status Indians, including Bishop Anderson's grandparents, escaped social discrimination
by converting to Christianity and taking another Christian name. But elsewhere in the British
Empire, names were connected with something completely un-Christian, slavery. Black British writer
Professor Robert Beckford is an activist theologian at the University of Winchester. His surname,
Beckford, is a slave name, passed down from his enslaved African ancestors in 18th century Jamaica.
Here Professor Beckford talks to BBC World Service programme, Hathen Sol, about his decision
to name his son, Micah. Before my son is named Micah, Micah Beckford after one of the prophets.
So I do like the idea of people in the biblical tradition who speak truth to power, who ruffle
people's feathers, who challenge the injustice. I haven't thought of giving myself a biblical name.
I could never find a name that really resonated with me. The phrase to speak truth to power
describes times when people non-violently resist an oppressive force, such as a government
or corporation, by telling the truth. And if you ruffle someone's feathers, you upset or annoy them.
Maybe it's not so much your name as what you do with it that counts. Anyway, it's time to
reveal the answer to your question, Neil. Yes, I asked you which boy's name is currently the world's
most popular and you guessed Muhammad, which was the correct answer. Right, let's recap the vocabulary
we've learned, starting with injustice, a situation lacking fairness or justice.
In British English, your Christian name is your first name. The name you are given at birth.
The adjective noble means admirable or morally good. Baggage refers to beliefs and feelings,
especially outdated or unhelpful ones, which influence how someone thinks.
The idiom speak truth to power describes when people non-violently resist an oppressive force,
such as a government or corporation, by telling the truth. And finally, to ruffle someone's
feathers means to upset or annoy them. Once again, our six minutes are up. But remember to join us
again next time for more trending topics and useful vocabulary here at six minutes English.
Goodbye for now. Bye.